you probably know I'm someone who's more
used to court reporting than reporting
on Royal events or if I do report on
Royal events then Prince Harry's
normally on a balcony or flashing by in
a carriage and so this was extremely
weird and surreal to see him in the
court space
giving evidence in in a case like this
and he was the next thing to say really
is he was up against obviously someone
in Andrew Green KC who is you know
trained to make people look like they
don't know what they're talking about
um you know he's a top Barrister and
Harry was really coming under Fire
actually started quite softly
um with uh the the Barrister who's
representing the mirror saying look if
if I say anything that's unduly
intrusive you have to let me know and he
apologized for the one thing that the
mirror has accepted that they did wrong
which was some reporting around him
visiting a nightclub but then really the
gloves came off and the attacks came I
thought it was kind of three-pronged
really the first thing was that he was
saying essentially a lot of the these
articles you didn't read at the time so
they couldn't have really caused you
distress he referred to an article that
was written when he was just aged 11 and
he said you know if you didn't read it
um how can you say the article caused
you distress and Harry replied well it
had an effect on my life and the people
around me my mother in this case and it
was an article about him being rushed to
hospital by his Nanny but then the next
line of attack was really saying that a
lot of this information that he's saying
came from hacking was actually already
in the public domain so he gives
examples for example where uh he was
claiming that there was an article about
him going climbing with his brother and
the mirror had published this article he
said it actually already been published
two days before in the Daily Mirror all
that sorry in the Daily Mail all that
information was already out there and
the Sunday papers had it as well so how
could he say that this this came from
hacking and then the the third line of
attack really is he's saying really
what's cool causing you distress is that
things like you being accused of drug
taking stuff like that is is causing you
embarrassment but it's not the method by
which these articles are obtained and
his essential point that the law I
representing the mirror is saying you
can't prove that these articles have
been uh obtained through hacking or
other means using private investigators
especially when what would be the point
of doing that if a lot of this
information is already out there and
what Harry has essentially been saying
is that the mirror group is known for
hacking it's it's had previous with
hacking and that he was one of the most
high profile figures of that time there
were hundreds of Articles written about
him and it's almost ridiculous to
suggest that he wasn't hacked and people
around him weren't hacked but when it
comes to the specifics of each article
he's saying well which whose phone was
hacked what piece of information came
from this nefarious techniques and
that's where Harry is stumbling but is
one get out line that he has been using
a couple of times he's saying well if
you if you want to know the answer to
that why didn't you ask the journalist
who wrote the article and I'm sure that
his lawyers have told him to say that
because a lot of these journalists from
the mirror group are not turning up to
give evidence here so Harry is making
the point look here I am okay you may be
getting me on a few points here but I've
got the courage to come and give
evidence well why aren't these
journalists giving evidence what have
they got to hide